pour la politique un rapport d'expertisé
dénoncent la dangerosité d'un coupe-faim
mis sur le marché en 86 et qui aura
entraîné la mort de 30 personnes de par
le monde cette pilule l'isoméride a été
prescrite à 7 millions de personnes en
france son efficacité certaine
mais ces effets secondaires dans des cas
extrêmes sont à l'origine de maladies
cardiaques et pulmonaires très grave se
produit a été retiré totalement du
marché en septembre dernier reste des
victimes
reportage daniel wolfromm marques millet
cette jeune femme n'a franchement pas de
chance elle a contracté une maladie rare
et grave l'hypertension artérielle
pulmonaire après un traitement
amaigrissant à l'isoméride un médicament
coupe faim
une centaine de cas similaires ont été
décelés en france depuis 1985
anna est bien décidé à prendre ses
affaires en main son histoire à elle
remonte à 1991 quand son médecin lui
recommande tout simplement de perdre
quelques kilos après son accouchement en
quinze jours j'ai perdu 6 kg et après
que ce qui s'est passé et après j'ai
commencé à être à essouffler je faisais
comme des crises d'asthme et pendant
longtemps les médecins avaient conclu
que je faisais de l'asthme jusqu'au jour
j'ai fait un malaise je suis arrivée à
l'hôpital on m'avait dit que c'était pas
du tout au tout ensuite ils m'ont
annoncé qu'il fallait une greffe des
poumons
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de guérison
pour cette maladie et elle était arrivée
avec la finale je ne vais pas qu'on
entend à vire qu'est ce que vous allez
faire maintenant bien maintenant
j'essaye de nous battre pour que ça se
reconnaissent tous se battre pour la
pole hausse étalée devant les tribunaux
un rapport d'experts saisis l'an dernier
vient de rendre des conclusions qui lui
sont favorables
à l'heure actuelle son hypertension
pulmonaire compte tenu de l'absence de
tout incident chez cette femme doit être
lié à l'isoméride et la littérature
médicale au fort mal à ce sujet par
contre le laboratoire servier fabricant
du médicament ni le lien de causalité
entre l'isoméride et la maladie d' anna
lisa mérite comme le pondéral présentés
comme des produits miracles ont été
consommés par des millions de patients
en
ans l'obésité touche 7 à 10% de la
population l'isoméride a été absorbée
pendant dix ans sans modération mais 95
une étude internationale incriminent les
coupes faim dans les hypertensions
artérielles
les premiers les français prennent des
mesures l'isoméride est massivement
retiré de la vente et n'est plus
délivrés que pour des cas d'obésité
majeur en 97
le produit disparaisse complètement du
marché mondial nous avons envoyé depuis
le début de l'année dernière aux
médecins une circulaire pour qu'il nous
dise si dans leur clientèle certains
pourraient être victimes de ces
médicaments
il faut pour rassurer les gens dire que
ces atteintes là c'est à dire
l'hypertension pulmonaire en particulier
survient en général dans la première
année de consommation
cette coupe faim reste sur le marché
aujourd'hui ils sont réservés aux
obésité pathologique sous strict
contrôle médical et pour des périodes
très limité